この度は、私、はじめしゃちょーに関する一連の騒動についてお話ししたいと思います。
ただいま、沢山の事実である情報、
そして、事実とは異なる情報がネット上に出回っておりますが...
この件に関しまして、大勢の視聴者の皆さま、
そして、関係者の皆さまをお騒がせしてしまい、
誠に申し訳ございませんでした。
今回はその件についてお話させて頂きたいと思います。
ただいま、ネット上で言われている情報が大きく分けて3つございます。
1つ目は、私が以前お付き合いさせていただいていた女性についてです。
2つ目は、その以前お付き合いさせていただいた女性との交際期間中に、他の女性と関係を持っていたという情報。
3つ目は、以前お付き合いさせていただいていた女性との交際期間が、それ以前に付き合っていた女性との交際期間が被っていた、という件についてです。
まず一つ目です。
私が以前、お付き合いさせていただいていた女性についてお話させていただきます。
現在、その女性が、私と以前付き合っていた時にあった内容や画像、LINEの情報などをネット上に公開し、
その内容が真実かどうかという疑惑が発生しておりますが、
この件に関しまして、その女性と私が以前お付き合いしていたことは事実でございます。
2つ目は、その女性の証言の中に「交際期間中に私が他の女性と関係を持っていた」という発言に関しまして、
こちらからお話したいことがございます。
細かい内容をお話しさせて頂きますと、
2月の14日、私の誕生日に、
以前お付き合いさせていただいていた女性に「2月14日の予定は空いていないか」というお話をいただいたところ、
私の方では「既に友人との予定や動画の撮影、編集などがあり、当日は会えない」
という返信をしたにも関わらず、当日に他の女性を家に泊めていた
といった内容のものです。
こちらの件に関しましては、先に事実を述べさせていただきますと、
2月14日は多忙だったために予定を入れられなっかったものの、
その後、2月15日の午前3時ごろに、友人の女性が私の家に来て泊まりに来ていたことは事実でございます。
この情報がどこからリークしたかといいますと、私本人が、
以前お付き合いしていた女性にお話ししたために、彼女本人からの情報が出回っております。
実際にその時自宅に来ていた女性は、私とは友人関係であり、
友人としての付き合いが短いわけでもなく信頼のできる友人であり、時間的にも帰ることができなかったために
その女性が泊まって行っても何も問題はないと私が判断致しました。
こちらとしては、友人だったので、当時付き合っていた彼女に14日のことを聞かれたタイミングで
やましいことは一切していないので直接お話しました。
事実を話させていただきますと、その女性とは一切そういった関係はなく
現在付き合っているという事実もございません。
ただ、当時付き合っていた女性の見方からすると
その女性と関係を持っていると勘違いされても仕方のない、私の甘い判断だったと思っております。
3つ目は、私が以前付き合っていた女性との交際期間が
それ以前に付き合っていた女性との交際期間に被っていたということについてです。
この件に関しましては事実でございます。
私が以前付き合っていた女性とお付き合いする前に
その以前にお付き合いしていた女性に別れを切り出していたのですが
お互いの忙しさや意見の食い違いなどにより話がまとまらず
交際期間が被ってしまったという時間がありました。
その期間に関しましては、私の未熟な判断により双方の女性に不快な思いをさせてしまったことを
大変申し訳なく思っております。
この度は大勢の方に大変なご心配をおかけしてしまい、誠に申し訳ございませんでした。